Wait, hey mom, you want to say hi? It's good podcast content. So here's the magic number. The magic number is two? Yes. Can you tell me what it's the number of at the ACCU conference? I do not know. Well, I just came back from the bar and I counted two women amongst maybe, oh, I don't know, 50 or 60 computer bros. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 179, recorded on April 17th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about the problem that took Twitter by storm, check grade, get a guest appearance from Bryce's mom, and talk about one other thing because it's so topical and you,
等等，嘿妈妈，你想打个招呼吗？这是很好的播客内容。那么，神奇数字来了。神奇数字是二？是的。你能告诉我它在 ACCU 大会上代表什么吗？我不知道。好吧，我刚从酒吧回来，数了数，在大概，哦，我不知道，50 或 60 个电脑兄弟中，只有两名女性。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 179 期，录制于 2024 年 4 月 17 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，聊聊那个席卷 Twitter 的问题，检查成绩，还有 Bryce 妈妈的客串，以及聊聊另一件事，因为它非常热门，而你，
you just, you're just going to have to find a way to work it into, um, you're just going to have to find a way to work it in. Sorry. We will see. Maybe, maybe not. Let's, let's talk about check grade. Oh, oh yeah. You want to, you want to summarize for the listener what CheckGrade is? No, no. You're the one that brought the tweet up. So you tell your story how you – because I only stumbled across it because you sent it to me. So you tell the origin story. So CheckGrade has been a collective Twitter code golf moment that has been unfolding this week, where some poor soul tweeted about
你只是，你只是得想办法把它加进去，嗯，你只是得想办法把它加进去。抱歉。我们会看到的。也许吧，也许不会。让我们，让我们谈谈检查成绩（CheckGrade）。哦，哦，是的。你想，你想为听众总结一下 CheckGrade 是什么吗？不，不。是你提起的推文。所以你来讲讲你的故事，你是怎么——因为我只是因为你发给我才偶然发现它的。所以你来讲讲起源故事。所以 CheckGrade 是本周在 Twitter 上展开的一场集体代码高尔夫（code golf）时刻，当时有个可怜的家伙发推文提到了
this problem. And then everybody on the internet and their dog had an opinion. And at first, there were a lot of serious opinions and responses posted. And then there were a lot of amusing ones posted. But the problem is so we got a function check grade. Check grade takes an integer that is a score or a grade. So it's between
这个问题。然后互联网上的每个人和他们的狗都有了意见。起初，有很多严肃的意见和回复被发布出来。然后又有很多有趣的回复。但问题是，我们有一个函数 check grade。Check grade 接收一个整数，即分数或成绩。所以它在
0 and 100. And it's going to return you a string or really just a character, of a letter grade. You know, A being 90 and up to 100, or really 90 and higher. B being 80 up to 90. C being 70 up to 80. D being 60 up to 70, and F being anything below 60. So this poor soul called this the arrow anti-pattern because the first version that he wrote or that he tweeted about had like
0 到 100 之间。它会返回一个字符串，或者实际上只是一个字符，代表字母等级。你知道，A 是 90 到 100，或者说 90 及以上。B 是 80 到 90。C 是 70 到 80。D 是 60 到 70，F 是 60 以下的任何分数。所以这个可怜的家伙称之为箭头反模式（arrow anti-pattern），因为他写的或者他发推文提到的第一个版本有像
a big nested if loop, a bunch of nested if statements. Sorry. So he had like an if score is larger than or equal to 90, then return A, else, and then the else logic had, you know, if score larger than or equal to 80, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, recursing down to handling all the cases. And his refactoring that he posted as a reply, and this guy was writing code in Java. We're not going to hold that against him. His refactoring, he creates a dictionary of integers to strings and then looks them up in the dictionary.
一个巨大的嵌套 if 循环，一堆嵌套的 if 语句。抱歉。所以他写了类似如果分数大于或等于 90，则返回 A，否则，然后 else 逻辑里有，你知道，如果分数大于或等于 80，等等，等等，等等，递归下去处理所有情况。而他作为回复发布的重构版本，这家伙是用 Java 写的代码。我们不会因此而对他有偏见。他的重构是创建了一个从整数到字符串的字典，然后在字典中查找它们。
And that is not the worst possible solution, but it's a pretty bad one. Because why use a dictionary when you could just use a simple array? And some people posted responses that just used to look up into a simple array. And some people posted responses that just used a lookup into a simple array. But as other people pointed out, like anything that's going to involve a memory access is going to potentially be slow and you could just do some clever math instead. So yeah, and it just sort of spiraled out and people, you know, people had opinions about like,
这并不是最糟糕的解决方案，但相当糟糕。因为既然可以用简单的数组，为什么要用字典呢？有些人发布的回复只是使用了简单的数组查找。有些人发布的回复只是使用了简单的数组查找。但正如其他人指出的那样，任何涉及内存访问的东西都可能很慢，你其实可以用一些巧妙的数学运算来代替。所以，是的，它就这样蔓延开了，人们，你知道，人们对类似这样的事情有看法，
okay, should you do this with a switch statement? you is it okay to use early returns like just switch over the um the grades or just like have some if statements with early returns um and uh yeah i mean like like you know if you look at the if statement with early return it it does look pretty elegant but apparently some people really dislike early returns. I think I saw Jonathan Mueller post something about it. I started seeing a bunch of C++ people posting about it. And my, of course, first and immediate reaction was, well, okay, how do we write this in a way that can be lowered down into SIMD masks and will not actually have any branching. And some people came up with clever solutions that'll do that.
好吧，你应该用 switch 语句来做吗？使用提前返回（early returns）可以吗，比如直接对成绩进行 switch，或者只是用一些带有提前返回的 if 语句；嗯，是的，我的意思是，如果你看看带有提前返回的 if 语句，它看起来确实很优雅，但显然有些人真的很讨厌提前返回。我想我看到 Jonathan Mueller 发过关于它的内容。我开始看到一堆 C++ 的人在讨论它。当然，我的第一反应是，好吧，我们如何以一种可以降低为 SIMD 掩码且实际上没有任何分支的方式来编写它。有些人想出了一些巧妙的解决方案来做到这一点。
I don't have any of them in front of me, but there's some stuff you can do with some divisions and multiplications and some clever math where it'll just get you to the right answer without needing any actual branching. It may not be the cleanest code, but it is going to be pretty fast code, or at the very least pretty, yeah, I'll stick with fast.
我手头没有这些方案，但你可以通过一些除法、乘法和一些巧妙的数学运算来做一些事情，这样你就能得到正确答案，而不需要任何实际的分支。它可能不是最整洁的代码，但它会是相当快的代码，或者至少，是的，我会坚持说是快的。
It may not be efficient code because it may be doing, it may be more math-heavy than you'd want, but in a parallel context, that's fine if it avoids thread divergence. Yeah, but I suppose I just wanted to get my two cents in on this. I suppose the solutions I probably liked best were those clever mathy ones or the lookup in a constant array ones. Because I think that a compiler will lower the look up in an array down to something pretty good. Like into like some sort of like jump table or something,
它可能不是高效的代码，因为它可能比你想要的更依赖数学运算，但在并行上下文中，如果它能避免线程分歧，那没问题。是的，但我认为我只是想就此发表一下我的看法。我想我最喜欢的解决方案是那些巧妙的数学运算方案或常量数组查找方案。因为我认为编译器会将数组查找降低为相当不错的东西。比如某种跳转表之类的，
or it'll just lower it down into the clever math. But I haven't looked at that deeply. But I do feel, I do generally feel for this fellow who posted this solution, who posted this problem because it got like 600 retweets and like four million views and a lot of people shit on his on his answer. And, you know, I think, I think somebody, you know, wanting to find a better way of doing things, even if they're, even if their first attempt isn't, isn't that great, like, you know, just getting out there and, and making the effort and asking for help is like, that's more than what a lot of people do so uh yeah like i feel like that should be encouraged not uh uh punished by the internet yep we will link the
或者它会直接将其降低为巧妙的数学运算。但我没有深入研究过。但我确实，我确实为这个发布解决方案、发布这个问题的人感到难过，因为它获得了大约 600 次转发和 400 万次浏览，很多人对他的答案嗤之以鼻。而且，你知道，我认为，我认为有人，你知道，想要找到更好的做事方式，即使他们的第一次尝试不是，不是那么好，就像，你知道，只是走出去，做出努力并寻求帮助，这比很多人做的要多，所以，是的，我觉得这应该受到鼓励，而不是被互联网惩罚，是的，我们会链接到
tweet my my couple thoughts are one i don't see what's wrong with early return i mean if it was in python right and you were using a rough linter like literally you could have just gone rough fix i actually i should make a youtube video i'll make a youtube video what is rough rough are you ff it's basically a implementation of like every single type checker linter pep standard formatter it's like imagine all of the stuff in c++ clang format clang tidy asan you know fsan all the sanitizers all the linters cpp check include what you use imagine like someone created a tool that just re-implements all of that and they re-implemented it in rust that's what basically this rough project is for python so if you've heard of like
推文。我的几个想法是，第一，我不明白提前返回有什么问题，我的意思是，如果它是在 Python 中，对吧，而且你正在使用像 Ruff 这样的 linter，字面上你本可以直接运行 ruff fix。其实我应该做一个 YouTube 视频，我会做一个 YouTube 视频，什么是 Ruff？Ruff，R-U-F-F，它基本上是每一个类型检查器、linter、PEP 标准格式化程序的实现。就像想象一下 C++ 中所有的 clang-format、clang-tidy、asan，你知道，fsan，所有的 sanitizers，所有的 linters，cppcheck，include-what-you-use，想象一下有人创建了一个工具，重新实现了所有这些，而且他们是用 Rust 重新实现的，这就是这个 Ruff 项目对 Python 的意义。所以如果你听说过像
mypy as a type checker or if you've heard of you know the pep8 you know standards and linters and stuff they're implementing all of it so uh the point is i don't actually know which one of the linters uh warns you about early return but one of them does and rough comes with the similar to clang format and clang tidy where you can give it a dash dash fix and it'll just fix it for you and if you were to do this like you know if greater than 90 print or like return this else then indent indent indent it i'm pretty sure rough would just collapse all of that into like five if statements with returns uh because the the lint says like you don't need an else when the only like your previous branch is returning, which I think is completely great.
mypy 这样的类型检查器，或者如果你听说过 PEP8 标准和 linters 之类的东西，他们正在实现所有这些。所以，重点是，我其实不知道是哪个 linter 会警告你关于提前返回的问题，但其中一个会。而且 Ruff 带有类似于 clang-format 和 clang-tidy 的功能，你可以给它一个 --fix，它就会直接为你修复它。如果你要这样做，你知道，如果大于 90 打印或返回这个，否则缩进缩进缩进，我很确定 Ruff 会把所有这些折叠成类似五个带有返回的 if 语句，因为 lint 说，当你的前一个分支已经返回时，你不需要 else，我觉得这完全没问题。
The sad thing about Python formatting is that it's going to put the return on a separate line, whereas I think it looks a lot nicer if it's just on a single line. But hey, that's just my personal preference. My second thought, though, is all this fancy math that you describe in order to get lowered down into SIM onto a SIMD. Uh, first of all, anybody, whenever anyone ever says SIMD, that's just a fancy way of saying array programming. And second of all, it's not, it's, it's not fancy math. Like my very first, my first thought was like, just do the early returns.
关于 Python 格式化，可悲的是它会把 return 放在单独的一行，而我认为如果它只在一行上会好看得多。但嘿，那只是我的个人偏好。不过我的第二个想法是，你描述的所有这些为了降低到 SIMD 上的花哨数学运算。首先，任何人，每当有人提到 SIMD，那只是数组编程的一个花哨说法。其次，它不是，它不是花哨的数学。就像我的第一个想法是，直接用提前返回。
You're just going to drop that on me and expect me to to just take it yeah like i've listened to i've listened to an episode on what is what is richard feldman's podcast called it should be called the rock programming podcast but it's called functional something anyways link in the description to the episode. And he has an episode where he talks to the implementer of SIMD JSON. And every little tool and technique that they describe in that episode is just array programming. Like it's just array programming, building up masks instead of using ifs, et cetera, or finding indices. Yes, but I'll put in the caveat that sometimes you have to write code in a very specific way to get it to vectorize correctly with a particular compiler or on a particular platform. That is not like, yeah, sometimes you use high level, like more abstract ideas to write code that's going to be SIMD efficient. But sometimes it's like, oh, well, you know, like we need to use, you know, this math operation here instead of that
你就要把这个扔给我，指望我直接接受吗？是的，就像我听过 Richard Feldman 的播客的一集，它应该叫 Rock 编程播客，但它叫函数式什么的，总之，描述中有该集的链接。他有一集是和 SIMD JSON 的实现者交谈。他们在那一集中描述的每一个小工具和技术都只是数组编程。就像它只是数组编程，构建掩码而不是使用 if，等等，或者寻找索引。是的，但我会加一个警告，有时你必须以非常特定的方式编写代码，才能让它在特定的编译器或特定的平台上正确向量化。这不像，是的，有时你使用高级的、更抽象的想法来编写 SIMD 高效的代码。但有时它是，哦，好吧，你知道，我们需要在这里使用这个数学运算而不是那个
math operation, because on this particular x86 microarchitecture, you know, that's more efficient. Okay, so sure, feel free to add that asterisk. But what I was going to say is that the fancy math is a subtraction, an integer division, and a maximum. Yeah. But I think people don't like the fancy math because it's not. That's not fancy math. That's not fancy math. Three binary operations.
数学运算，因为在特定的 x86 微架构上，这更有效率。好吧，当然，请随意加上那个星号。但我想说的是，那些花哨的数学运算就是减法、整数除法和最大值。是的。但我认为人们不喜欢花哨的数学运算，因为它们不是。那不是花哨的数学。那不是花哨的数学。三个二进制运算。
People don't like it because it makes it a lot less clear what the function is doing. It does make it faster. And I would definitely write that like, and if a lot less clear what the function is doing. It does make it faster. And I would definitely write that like, and if you want to know what the function is doing, like put the slow version in the comments. Like put the version that's easy to read, like that's clear and concise. Just put that in the comments, right? And then put the fast thing that like is not as clear like in the code i i think it's a red herring to say that it's harder to read just people people can look at
人们不喜欢它，因为它让函数在做什么变得不那么清晰。它确实让它变快了。我肯定会那样写，如果，如果你想知道函数在做什么，把慢的版本放在注释里。把容易阅读、清晰简洁的版本放在注释里，对吧？然后把那个不那么清晰但很快的东西放在代码里。我认为说它更难阅读是一个误导，人们，人们可以看
an if you know a set of if statements and returns and i guess because they're used to if statements and returns but like index calculating an index and indexing into a string inside a one-line function that's called check grade i don't think like anybody would have any no uh buddy i i just agree strongly i i think like if if if if a human like thinks about like how our our head processes it um like like how we would think about it and describe it i'll describe it to other people we would describe it closer to the early return if it like if version than to the indexing into a string this is why i said the other episode that the array community is the best community because they think the right way everyone it's
一个 if，你知道，一组 if 语句和返回，我想是因为他们习惯了 if 语句和返回，但像计算索引并在单行函数中索引字符串，这个函数叫 check grade，我不认为任何人会，不，伙计，我强烈不同意。我认为如果，如果，如果一个人思考我们的大脑是如何处理它的，嗯，就像我们如何思考它并向其他人描述它，我们会把它描述得更接近提前返回的 if 版本，而不是索引到字符串。这就是为什么我在另一集里说数组社区是最好的社区，因为他们以正确的方式思考。每个人，它是
easier for people to think about it that way because that's just the way that they've been reading code and writing code the whole time but if you're used to seeing this like you're such an array language nationalist i don't think it has anything to do with nationalism but uh you know replace that word with another word and sure just sign me up it's it's the right way it's the it's the way it's the way to think everybody's everybody's hopping on the bandwagon i mean you hopped on the bandwagon it's great folks we'll link the simd simd json episode we'll link the tweet well there's an answer here that i gotta show you that i i think is somebody's serious answer but i i deeply hope it's somebody's joke answer.
人们更容易那样思考，因为那是他们一直阅读和编写代码的方式。但如果你习惯了看到这个，你真是个数组语言民族主义者。我不认为这与民族主义有任何关系，但，你知道，用另一个词替换那个词，当然，算我一个。这是正确的方式，这是思考的方式。每个人都在赶时髦。我的意思是，你也赶时髦了，这很棒。各位，我们会链接到 SIMD JSON 那一集，我们会链接到那条推文。好吧，这里有一个答案我得给你看，我认为这是某人的严肃回答，但我深深希望这是某人的玩笑回答。
Wait, it hasn't shared yet. I mean, maybe it's not so bad. No, it's pretty bad, right? So what this person has is they have a switch statement where they've got, you know, case 100, and then they have case 99, colon case 98, colon case 97, colon case 96, have case 99, case 98, case 97, case 96, case 95, all the way down to case 90. And they have formatted it nicely. And looking at it, it is not as bad as I thought because, you know, there's not actually that many cases that you have to handle.
等等，还没分享呢。我的意思是，也许没那么糟。不，这很糟糕，对吧？所以这个人有的是一个 switch 语句，他们有，你知道，case 100，然后他们有 case 99，冒号 case 98，冒号 case 97，冒号 case 96，有 case 99，case 98，case 97，case 96，case 95，一直到 case 90。而且他们格式化得很好。看着它，它并没有我想象的那么糟，因为，你知道，实际上并没有那么多情况需要处理。
You only have to have like 40 cases and then you can default to F for the rest. But yeah, there's one person who seemed to... And of course, the person wrote, C has a simple and elegant solution to this. So I'm going to assume they're a C person, which is why they would consider this to be serious code. But yeah, their solution is just a switch statement with uh 41 cases and some nice formatting yeah i don't know why you would do this over the if returns but i'm pretty sure he's just trolling or they're just trolling i don't think they're trolling because i've seen like i've seen people's answers to this who are not trolling and are who are trolling and they make it a lot more ridiculous. This to me is somebody's attempt to make this particular
你只需要有 40 个 case，然后剩下的默认返回 F 就可以了。但是的，有一个人似乎……当然，那个人写道，C 语言对此有一个简单而优雅的解决方案。所以我假设他们是 C 语言用户，这就是为什么他们会认为这是严肃的代码。但是的，他们的解决方案只是一个带有 41 个 case 和一些漂亮格式的 switch 语句。是的，我不知道为什么你会为了这个而放弃 if 返回，但我很确定他只是在钓鱼，或者他们只是在钓鱼。我不认为他们在钓鱼，因为我见过，我见过人们对这个问题的回答，他们不是在钓鱼，而且他们让它变得更加荒谬。对我来说，这是某人试图让这种特定的
approach look elegant. Oh, I mean, I don't know. It's not like it does actually look not that bad. Looking at 41 case statements here, like it's not as ugly as I thought it was going to be. But still, like, you know, like, think about it, like, think how bug prone this is, like, all you have to do is make one mistake in one of these, like, you know, like you accidentally you wrote case 95 twice and and you left out case 94 and then you've got this inscrutable bug in your code oh oh people people people people well there you have it folks hopefully accu is good i mean by the time the listener is hearing me say that accu is over but uh i hope you enjoy it yeah so um i am one i'm gonna see you in july because i'm going to c++ north oh maybe i'll keep that in yeah congrats uh which talk i also got accepted as well so we'll both
方法看起来优雅的尝试。哦，我的意思是，我不知道。它看起来确实没那么糟。看着这里的 41 个 case 语句，它不像我想象的那么丑。但仍然，像，你知道，想想看，这有多容易出错，像，你所要做的就是在其中一个里犯一个错误，像，你知道，你意外地写了两次 case 95，漏掉了 case 94，然后你的代码里就有了这个难以捉摸的 bug。哦，哦，人们，人们，人们，人们。好吧，各位，这就是结果。希望 ACCU 大会很棒。我的意思是，当听众听到我说这句话时，ACCU 已经结束了，但我希望你们喜欢它。是的，所以，嗯，我，我会在七月见到你，因为我要去 C++ North。哦，也许我会保留那一点。恭喜，哪个演讲？我也被录取了，所以我们都会
you know if you're going to my talk think parallel got accepted um but uh uh i do not know what version of think parallel people will be seen at uh at uh c++ north it might be a refinement of think parallel scans it might be a different think parallel part oh you gotta you gotta bring us part two because by that point the accu one will be online and then uh you gotta you gotta keep the content coming you've already talked about it i think that c++ north will likely be um the rolling reduce one and that's fantastic because my talk is also a part two talk not of an accu talk but of the talk that I gave last year, Composition of Intuition.
你知道，如果你要参加我的演讲 Think Parallel，它被录取了，但，嗯，我不知道人们在 C++ North 会看到什么版本的 Think Parallel。它可能是 Think Parallel Scans 的改进版，也可能是不同的 Think Parallel 部分。哦，你得，你得给我们带来第二部分，因为到那时 ACCU 的那个就会上线了，然后，你得，你得保持内容更新。你已经谈过它了，我认为 C++ North 很可能会是那个 Rolling Reduce 的演讲，那太棒了，因为我的演讲也是一个第二部分演讲，不是 ACCU 演讲的第二部分，而是我去年做的演讲，Composition of Intuition 的第二部分。
So we'll both be giving part two talks, which is a good story. You got to tell them to not schedule us against each other because I want to see your talk. That should be fine. I mean, ours are too closely related, right? Like algorithms and algorithms, you know? Yeah. The talk I was really excited for at
所以我们都会做第二部分演讲，这是一个很好的故事。你得告诉他们不要把我们的演讲安排在同一时间，因为我想看你的演讲。那应该没问题。我的意思是，我们的演讲关联太紧密了，对吧？比如算法和算法，你知道？是的。我非常期待的那个演讲在
this conference is now scheduled at the same time as my talk so that's unfortunate and and and yes kevlin i i am talking about your talk wow well yeah hopefully you get to see it online i know that uh bjorn faller he's given the closing keynote and I always love his talks. So that should be. I'm pretty sure I will not be around for that because I'm going to be on a plane briefly after my talk going to Dingle, Ireland. And if you've never heard of Dingle, Ireland, that's because it is in the middle of nowhere. It is in Kerry County on the far west, southwest part of Ireland. So yeah, I'll be there for a little while. Fun. Why are you going there? Just for fun?
这次大会上现在和我的演讲安排在同一时间，所以这很不幸。而且，是的，Kevlin，我是在说你的演讲。哇，好吧，是的，希望你能在线看到它。我知道 Bjorn Faller 他做了闭幕主题演讲，我一直很喜欢他的演讲。所以那应该会很棒。我很确定我不会在那里，因为我会在演讲后不久就去机场，前往爱尔兰的丁格尔（Dingle）。如果你从未听说过爱尔兰的丁格尔，那是因为它在荒郊野外。它位于爱尔兰西南部远端的凯里郡（Kerry County）。所以是的，我会在那里待一会儿。有趣。你为什么去那里？只是为了好玩吗？
My mom has a friend who has a house there. So we're going there. Nice. Yeah. Look at you, globetrotting. Globetrotting? nice yeah look at you globe trotting globe trotting yes i it's like it's bad man it's bad i have um so the american airlines uh like status qualifying year um starts march 1st and uh it's what april 17th and i have already nearly requalified for the top tier American Airlines status. I got to take a break. I've been on the road too much.
我妈妈有个朋友在那里有房子。所以我们要去那里。不错。是的，看看你，环球旅行。环球旅行？不错，是的，看看你环球旅行，环球旅行。是的，我，这就像，这很糟糕，伙计，这很糟糕。我有，嗯，美国航空的精英身份资格年度从 3 月 1 日开始，现在是 4 月 17 日，我已经几乎重新获得了美国航空最高级别的身份。我得休息一下。我在路上待得太久了。
Your carbon footprint has probably got to be one of the worst. Got to be one of the worst. I am one of the worst, yeah. I am. I am. All right. Well, hey, Mom, you want to say hi it's good podcast content so here's the magic number the magic number is two yes can you tell me what it's the number of
你的碳足迹可能是最糟糕的之一。肯定是最糟糕的之一。我是最糟糕的之一，是的。我是。我是。好吧。好吧，嘿，妈妈，你想打个招呼吗？这是很好的播客内容，所以神奇数字来了，神奇数字是二。是的，你能告诉我它在
at the accu conference i do not know well i just came back from the bar, and I counted two women. Amongst maybe, oh, I don't know, 50 or 60 computer bros. What's with that? I think that that's probably an accurate ratio. Although I will note that two of the keynotes are women. Well, maybe they were both there. I did actually think that the count was going to be three on my way to the elevator.
ACCU 大会上代表什么吗？我不知道。好吧，我刚从酒吧回来，我数了数，有两名女性。在大概，哦，我不知道，50 或 60 个电脑兄弟中。这是怎么回事？我认为这可能是一个准确的比例。虽然我会指出，其中两个主题演讲者是女性。好吧，也许她们都在那里。我在去电梯的路上确实以为人数会是三个。
However, it was just a guy with long hair and a ponytail. Bryce's mom doing damage in her first appearance on the podcast. That's not damage. I think it's amazing damage this is is i think it's amazing that this uh i was like it's damage to whoever had the long hair anyways uh yeah i'll look into it i'll make it happen folks if i have to wake if i have to wake up at you know 3 a.m uh it's not it's not the most difficult thing i've had to do for adsp the podcast uh we will do it what is the most difficult thing you've had to do for ADSP, the podcast.
然而，那只是一个留着长发和马尾辫的男人。Bryce 的妈妈在播客的第一次亮相中就造成了破坏。那不是破坏。我认为这是惊人的破坏。这是，我认为这很棒，这个，我当时想，这对那个留长发的人来说是破坏。总之，是的，我会调查一下，我会让它发生的，各位，如果我必须在，你知道，凌晨 3 点起床，这不是我为 ADSP 播客做过的最困难的事情，我们会做的。你为 ADSP 播客做过的最困难的事情是什么？
We will do it. What is the most difficult thing you've had to do for ADSP, the podcast? One time I had norovirus when I was in Mexico on vacation, and I was deathly ill for like 48 hours, and the podcast had to be launched in that window of time. Luckily, it had been edited but yeah i i was i like was barely moving i just crawled up in a fetal position you were in mexico dying of a virus and you still posted the podcast and this is the first i've ever heard of this. Really? I never mentioned it. You never mentioned it, which is bad because like most podcast co-hosts, like, you know, if you were dying of something, you'd be able to contact your co-host and be like, hey,
我们会做的。你为 ADSP 播客做过的最困难的事情是什么？有一次我在墨西哥度假时得了诺如病毒，我病得要死，持续了大约 48 小时，而播客必须在那段时间内发布。幸运的是，它已经剪辑好了，但是的，我，我几乎动弹不得，我只是蜷缩成胎儿姿势。你在墨西哥死于病毒，你还是发布了播客，这是我第一次听说这件事。真的吗？我从没提过。你从没提过，这很糟糕，因为像大多数播客联合主持人一样，你知道，如果你病得要死，你应该能联系你的联合主持人说，嘿，
can you do this this week? But I'm not that type of co-host. No, no, you're not. And it's only like 10 minutes of work, the actual publishing slash posting of it once it's edited. Yeah. So it still wasn't, you know, I hadn't broken my leg and was in the hospital and then had to get someone to bring my laptop so I could edit it while on, you know, morphine or something like that. In case you've broken your leg and are in the hospital. I don't.
这周你能做吗？但我不是那种类型的联合主持人。不，不，你不是。而且实际的发布/上传工作只有 10 分钟，一旦剪辑完成。是的。所以它仍然不是，你知道，我没有摔断腿在医院，然后不得不让人带我的笔记本电脑来，这样我就可以在服用吗啡或其他东西时剪辑它。万一你摔断了腿在医院。我不会。
I'll tell you what connor if you're if you are under general anesthesia um nothing local but if you're under general anesthesia i will take responsibility for getting the podcast posted uh sure i mean really my my my backup plan is if like everything really terribly, all we need to do is record. And then I just won't edit it. We'll splice the tracks and it'll be like episode whatever, 273. I feel like I should knock on wood there because that's going to be the one where I'm in the hospital. And then we'll just ship it.
我告诉你，Connor，如果你在全身麻醉下，嗯，不是局部麻醉，但如果你在全身麻醉下，我会负责把播客发布出去。当然，我的意思是，我的备份计划是，如果一切真的非常糟糕，我们只需要录音。然后我就不剪辑了。我们会拼接轨道，它会像第 273 期之类的。我觉得我应该敲敲木头，因为那将是我在医院的那一期。然后我们就会直接发布它。
There'll be no jingle. There'll be no intro. And it will be explained in the unedited version. And there won't be any show notes or anything. But it'll still get released. As long as it gets published, that's all that matters, truly, at the end of the day, for us to hit our... Consistency.
没有叮当声。没有片头。它会在未剪辑的版本中解释。也不会有节目笔记之类的。但它仍然会发布。只要它发布了，这就是最重要的，真的，归根结底，对我们来说，达到我们的……一致性。
You know, weeks. What is it? 179 at this point, as of this episode going out so we're we're getting there you know we're getting there wait wait is is is episode 200 gonna potentially be recorded when we're at c++ north no i believe episode 200 which is 30 episodes away, plus or minus, and it's like four in a month. So that's going to be several months. I think it's going to be in September of this year. Oh, okay.
你知道，几周了。是多少？到这一期发布时是 179 期，所以我们快到了，你知道我们快到了。等等，等等，第 200 期会不会在我们去 C++ North 时录制？不，我相信第 200 期，也就是 30 期之后，加减一点，一个月有四期。所以那将是几个月后。我认为那将是在今年的九月。哦，好吧。
All right. Well, I really should go because I desperately want to get to the gym. All righty. Good chatting. Enjoy the conference. Any last words, Mom? Have a good time at the gym and break your leg during your talk. Thank you. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthePodcast.com
好吧。好吧，我真的该走了，因为我非常想去健身房。好的。聊得很开心。享受会议。有什么临别赠言吗，妈妈？祝你在健身房玩得开心，并在你的演讲中摔断腿。谢谢。请务必在你的播客应用或 ADSPthePodcast.com 上查看这些节目笔记，
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这一期还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。